ce soir je reçois eric soir thierry et
ramzy avec un y bonsoir dans quelques
heures à me dit vous les connaissez sans
doute parce qu'on parle énormément de en
ce moment il cartonne sur fun tous les
soirs à 19h ils sont dans l'émission de
delarue de temps en temps et puis
surtout au théâtre du splendid à la
porte saint martin où on se marre
vraiment tous les soirs là c'est les
bourgs et moi j'y suis allé je me suis
marré et j'étais pas pourvu qu'elles
soient en fait j'ai vu une vendredi moi
je sais pas maintenant c'est vrai comme
tu veux ok si c'est un bon feeling je
voulais juste dire avant de commencer de
trucs pour la des corps immortel ceux
des copains et pour une émission qui
démarre comme ça vraiment et on a un
truc pour souhaiter bonne chance à toi
et moi c'est ça ça représente la scène
en quelques gestes les premiers à la
roseraie l'ancien truc que vous êtes les
premiers à vous en apercevoir à que tous
les gens qui viennent j'ai de l'argent
dans les airs et je crois que ce serait
un super titre et c'est bien parce qu'on
voulait sur paris première une chaîne du
câble ou satellite sonner si on peut
récupérer la pièce traite d'abord
puisque c'est pas la vraie c'est
normalement fin les gens le voient car
décor pour que les gens qui sont là les
blancs mais c'est bien parce que
personne s'en était aperçu ma tout le
monde m'a dit mais c'est quoi ce truc là
dans quoi tu sais la scène c'est un
merde faudrait que ça bosse chez les
bons les mecs alors vous êtes là pour
nous faire marrer le gac duo comique on
lui dit allez voici l'horaire
d'abord alors le splendide de vous y
êtes jusqu'à quand va faire un peu mal
au poignet jusqu'au 31 décembre
ouais ouais et ensuite on enchaîne avec
une très grande salle le palais des
glaces faur splendide c'est déjà une
grande salle ça contient 300 personnes
et nous on laboure bien puisque samedi
dernier on avait 8 181 personnes
et ma voyante elle a dit pour samedi
prochain
environ trente mille personnes non moi
j'ai vu la voyant de sa voyante elle
était bourré un tabac vous êtes au point
pour la promo là vous êtes peut faire
toutes les télés là vous êtes au parfum
c'est à dire que c'est vrai qu'on a pas
mal bossé nos télés avec une équipe de
80 personnes justement ouais on a
préparé ça en dehors grande pas avec un
attaché de presse avec une équipe les
gens regardent les à la télé donc les
invités mais ils savent pas que chaque
peut pas s'acheter les se prépare c'est
là que je rejoue eric a dit me lève et
je perde en bois en plus des pros qui
s'occupe de vous exact coluche qui nous
donnerait par nos textes et de données
bah oui mais sur un le luron pour les
imitations de laurent pour les pour les
inondations nick est bon bien sûr il ya
ceux qui bossent aussi un petit peu
paumé - niveau moi j'ai revu mon bon
alors vous vous sortez d'où là à
l'oreille avec toi explique moi moi je
viens de rien à voir avec le comique
rien à voir avec le théâtre comme ramzy
d'ailleurs moi j'étais guide guide
touristique abonde aux états unis au
canada tout ça je faisais visiter le
canada à des groupes de petits vieux
sympa et met sous laon au bout d'un
moment quand c'est à dire tuer des
vieilles oui bon c'est eux qui veut dire
c'est à dire pour oublier ce passé que
je me suis lancé sur la scène est ce que
tu te souviens à quel âge tu as fait
rire pour la première fois certains
parlent de six mois mois y croire jean
iv ma mère m'a dit que ma première
blague et c'est à l'âge de 6 mois et
demi maintenant je ne sais pas c'était
pendant l'échographie déjà non c'est
marrant parce qu'il était de 7 à
l'échographie choses vachement marée des
jamais
les économies que des imitations
d'imiter chirac il imitait le trophée
tués seront venues le fêter mes chiens
ouais mais c'est très très bien chez ma
grand mère voilà c'est fait il faut
imaginer un foetus cette imitation
tricherie on rit donc toi tu étais
guidon que tu faisais tomber les petits
faits dans les chutes du niagara non
alors jamais jamais tenté ce truc mais
ouais après on était je suis descendu
aussi en floride on descendait en visite
à la floride face à que j'ai aussi on
s'est même état des photos parce que on
continue donc tu reviens de je reviens
en france bon bah j'avais j'avais jamais
quitté vraiment la france puisque je
reviens tous les quinze jours
quand on part dans les voyages comme ça
et ensuite je reviens et puis j'ai bossé
pour une une boîte qui a racheté une
télé il ya pas longtemps
ah bon bouygues 1 tu as bossé pour
bouygues
j'en ai plus rien à [ __ ] moi ça y est
je bosse fera d'elle chez vous mais oui
directeur marketing
il était au troisième c'est vraiment
utilisé pour l'heure je faisais de la
logistique
oui ça vraiment ça va pas faire venir
les jours je pense un j'ai pas ça mais
c'est intéressant ou à débarquer dans ce
convoi pub où on veut savoir de votre
nom c'est vrai les gens dont tu bossais
pour briller que tu sais la logistique
je faisais de la logistique est en fait
c'était un peu un peu chiant 1 et j'ai
dit non tu peux parler aussi de toutes
les petites circulaire qui circulent la
chimie ig vrai avec un certain enfin
bref on va parler encore le voit ces
briques
après ça m'a saoulé un petit peu le vous
parce que logistique cci père qui la
télé c'est ben oui il ya télé téléphone
et logistique voilà tu as plusieurs
compartiments et pas dans le bon bout
menant et moi j'ai après logistique j'ai
choisi comique fâche faisait j'ai choisi
un truc qui finissait en ique
moi j'aurais pu finir alors jusqu'à ce
que tu deviennes comique qu'est ce que
tu as fait ben alors moi je suis sorti
de l'école je fais vendeur de fringues
le vendômois sympa
alors je vendais donc des pantalons
world est aussi des vues des pulls des
chevilles ce qui me permettait de
rencontrer les gens et c'est là que j'ai
développé mon sens du de la
communication force en moi c'est sûr
ceci dit de cela de caisse
voilà deux communes qui passait en est
et était au chic gap non mais c'est bien
non vous n'avez pas des mauvaises marque
quand même tout ça mais pas dans cette
rencontre et comment elle a alors c'est
à dire qu'il ya vraiment si c'est
l'homme qui faisait la teinte alors je
sais maintenant où est clair à ses
adieux
ça devait durer un soir ouais et puis
moi j'ai vu son numéro de téléphone
après sur le lit quoi un petit bout de
papier rouge à lèvres et puis si vous
allez je me rappelle bien fait marrer
allez on est parti comme ça pas que
marie c'était en quelle année sa 60e 89e
2 ans une des deux ans via deux enfants
et vous avez touché de décider de vous
mettre ensemble et depuis vous quittez
basse et là c'est beaucoup mais non
c'est vrai que je ne connaissais pas il
ya deux ans maintenant je passe dix
heures par jour avec lui j 1 avant
d'être d'eads avant d'être devenus de
vrais amis
on a commencé à travailler ensemble ça
c'est mon passage de sérieux c'est bien
c'est une statue peu le ressortir mon
arrêté mais j'écoute prime 1 j'ai pas
cool thing
comment ce qu'ils vont côté tribunes
groove latina août alors que vous avez
fait avant le donc ça a commencé comme
en un jour qui vous a découvert
olala chez drucker c'est le premier
n'empêche qui a pris le risque de nous
inviter en 3d jamais en dix ans michel
drucker c'est vrai c'est lui qui
découvrit mes habitudes à prendre jeudi
michel drucker sur 2 mai mais ouais
c'est un peu lui qu'au fn il n'a pas
découvert mais il a pris le risque de
nous prendre en plateau dans son
émission studio gabriel
alors que il avait rien vu de nous on
avait juste fait marrer dans le bureau
et c'est encore qu après notre passage
il a rien vu de nous non plus terribles
comme pas vrai fait quoi par exemple
première fois que vous l'avez vu heureux
car on est allé dans les bureaux et puis
bon on y aller avec tous nos
déguisements puisqu'on fait beaucoup
rire avec du déguisement comme ave
génial bon alors il ya eu une grosse
barbe du nez rouge en d3 confettis et
hop c'est dimanche vers un petit
accordéon
c'est les bonnes recettes qui font tueur
marais à lomme séduit dirais comme il
aime les chansonniers tu vois un coup
d'accordéon et qui coûte de parole le
virus est quoi le mieux dans votre
spectacle ce qu est ce qui est le plus
bas on a on a vachement alain griguer
retournement de question et toi qu'est
ce qui t'a fait le fussent mois ou un
mois c'est utile elle a baissé bien
c'est à ce personnage c'est comment du
tfc - voire nord du tilleul c'est c'est
pas montrable c'est à dire on a
justement ce problème c'est que on crée
en fait une espèce d'atmosphère fatah
vue pendant le spectacle
on dessine des personnages au fur et à
mesure on est séduit par eux ou pas c
reçoit les gens détestent sur les gens
adorent et au bout du bout de 20 minutes
tu rentres dans les personnages et les
trucs les running gag commences à te
faire marrer quand même vachement au
bout d'un certain temps alors sortir un
sketch comme ça en télé c'est pas facile
mais malgré tout thierry alet dû
découvrir
on va vers le même on va quand même lui
faire un extrait à nous la donner un de
nos meilleurs sketches à nos meilleurs
sketches mais dans ce cas il faudrait
qu'en suisse applique un petit peu le
temps que morel alors bon on a essayé
bien sûr je passe et un but dans ce
spectacle de sortir un petit peu des
sentiers battus parce qu'on a vu dans
les auditions ça il ya plein de fils
spirituel de dupontel des proches tout
ça et nous on a essayé de mêmes délié
dieudonné régis laspalès mais on est au
début vous foutez de
sa surprise le début c'est la surprise
en début ces cadeaux peric donc le mieux
au lieu de parler c'est de faire un
meilleur extrait de notre meilleur ski à
tout moment sans titre est parti cet
attentat la voilà on l'a un peu foiré
ouais la nuit la malfa mémoire et mais
moi j'étais bien dedans et puis en plus
sur scène bon il ya du décor la musique
seniors ii qu'il convoyait 104 le dédia
d'une musique qui soutient les cris et
ça passe voit que c'est pas les copains
vous dans la salle parce qu'ils se
marient vraiment sinon mais ya que des
amis une fois enregistré siméon ont
refait leur fait en dessous ça sera
peut-être moins bien parce que tu
comprends ça t'embête s'ouvrir et je
peux tomber en plus d'y arriver mieux là
ok c'est encore mieux passer ou pas
voilà encore une petite fois mais tu
vois juste en face que l'âge on est allé
au bout du viagra et puis ça fait deux
fois qu'on le foie a non la deuxième
fois c'était pas mal mais ouais ouais
parce que ça vient de moi je sais que
l'erreur est venue de moi je suis parti
je suis parti comme ça c'est un super ce
cas là si c'est vrai
un kit a plus ou pas dans le jeu mais
quand même alors qu'est ce que vous
foutez sur fun là tous les soirs
qu'est ce que vous foutez apprendre à
apprendre de la thune qu'est ce qu'on a
ils nous ont vus au point virgule on
faisait une audition et puis il était en
train de relooker la radio il changeait
des animateurs tout ça et puis nous on
dit tiens venez essayer une libre
antenne on a commencé un dimanche
la nuit avait aucune écoute rien du tout
d'une heure à 3h du mat et puis ça leur
a plu puis on a enchaîné quoi puis
maintenant on y est tous les jours
vous savez rabatteurs et puis on reçoit
des appels d'auditeurs et de la rue
qu'est ce vous faites ont fait une
rubrique ont défini des mots ça vient
d'une très bien la thur spectacle donc
j'ai laissé d une minute trente qui
passe une fois par semaine voilà et ça
marche bien
c'est ça qui marche en fait la demande
je sais me fait venir du monde n'empêche
que sans télé un spectacle y meurt vous
aimez chez la gaffe il ya un amour et
les curieux ouais c'est ce moment là que
je puisse de tarte à la crème je ne vois
pas de quoi vous voulez parler monsieur
lagaf et ben c'était une des premières
télés à nouveau les promos et il ya un
problème c'est que c'est une émission
enregistrée
donc il ya du montage donc ils passent
un peu l'image que rival de toi alors si
tu sors une vanne qui est un petit peu
piquante et qui va pas dans le moule la
graphique et d'une espèce de mentalisme
chez nous on a une salle à remplir aussi
bon ça va ça seront veulent pas se
vendre non plus n'ont pas de solution
déjà acheté ici nous ayons mais je sais
faire je t'ai appris les deux sans trois
bon alors pour conclure si vous aviez un
un seul truc à dire pour inviter pour
que les gens viennent vous voir au
splendid à vous diriez quoi bon alors ce
coup du mot de passe ou pas je sais pas
- non non un seul truc à dire c'est
qu'au moins tout au début les les les
deux premiers sketchs sont vraiment très
drôle quoi ils valent vraiment le coup
ouais tiens c'est quand même cinq
minutes vachement beau noël
je crois que doit servir pour ça après
ils peuvent se barrer peuvent se barrer
après ça peut devenir chiant mais en
tout cas les bords provient plaignant
c'est ses cinq premières minutes
souvenirs les saratars voilà ce qui
pourrait situer c'est pas le problème
bon vous allez vous séparer quand alors
parce que ce qui est drôle après dans
les comics dans les embrouilles c'est là
après embrouillamini on a commencé
direct parle embrouille déjà après il ya
eu réconciliation après embrouille donc
on est un peu habituels nous ça va se
passer comment la séparation que c'est
déjà pensé un peu noyonnais tristar
columbia pictures tv vous venez déjà
puis moi j'ai toujours ce concours
d'imitation dans le sud de la france
ok je veux participer
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu